baird di ragazze bevono solo vino sono
quello che fai video che i baffi adesso
un casino siamo tornati ragazzi si sfoga
heysel perchè non sacco ragazzi che non
lo gioco e mi sono ricordato che è
uscita appunto la stagione nuova è
infatti vola il casino delle mappe
incredibili e da un sacco di tempo che
voglio provare è uscito un pugno dal
muro tutto a posto ho smesso di giocarci
perché non c'è una volta va per nove
nella season 2 questa fa invece la
season di natale
vedo che almeno il primo livello non ho
mai visto la verità sembra roba
incredibile e niente malato casa non so
l'orto ai ragazzi stiamo dicendo la sisa
di natale mi sembra molto meno ma molto
molto molto meglio del dell'apd enti che
avevano fatto quello con la sito in due
non c'era così niente di nuovo quindi mi
sento che cosa devo fare come a parte
andare signore aiuto c'è una palla
enorme vabbé non importa sono vivo
ancora per poco però dai ragazzi
impossibile che io non so veramente come
fa come faccia dice sta roba
ponderatamente st parte si riesce a fare
quindi aspetto il mio turno tra verde si
aspetta il iv secolo una torta
no no no no
ottimo sono estasiato dal timore di
giocare ma che volete non ci sono la
vita ho preso in faccia e balle o tutto
speriamo faccia madonna ma solo bellino
ragazzi scusatemi cioè questo veramente
questo è un update di gioco questo lo è
non quello della season 2 hanno messo
tre map in croce qua a due mappe ho
fatto già tutte e due nuove
non so se è un caso e poi magari dati
tutto uguale nel solo primo sono
fortissimo non sono proprio prima perché
adesso quelli in cui i ragazzi aiuta e
vabbè una palla c'era latino perfetto la
signora pure un casino togli dei ragazzi
si scivola orribile sono io non ci credo
sono ancora in cassa non l'ho fatto
perfetto vai vai vai vai spina allora ok
ok ok e fin qua tutto male in realtà
però vabbè fa niente sto livello aiuto
togli tempo libero l'ho capito ma se
così parte una piazza partono con i tori
chi è venuto nel dubbio
no non ci credo sono vivo a posto arriva
32esimo rischiato di perdere ma stavolta
altre volte ci sono arrivate da questi
ragazzi sono difficilissimi ma no
ragazzi sono troppo protetto sono tutte
nuove 0 qui non hanno capito e passa
attraverso i buchi e bugo ecco questo
qua
ho vinto no a tutti felici ma ama non
sono eliminati come funziona lo capisco
ho capito non prima o poi arriveremo
alla fine faccio pagare a sta roba per
l'aspettavi devo prendere di adesso che
ho capito vai concentrare tutti i buchi
arrivare fino al 15 alle fino a qua ci
sono il problema quale è mai finita ed
ora è finito ma vabbè ragazzi sono
veramente storto che voleva 12 è questo
e poi è finito non c'è più niente a ti
puoi partire ok 10 15 11 da potrei fare
attenzione bellissimo alpa vi andava
bene anche questo un pezzo 15 quindi
l'obiettivo è prendere tipo quello delle
ricerche occidenti però è bellissimo
ragazzi e almeno un mese e mezzo che non
gioca e hanno messo delle cosè sta roba
delle cosi spinosi
ragazzi io non ho non sono proprio
sicuro di come fare questa mappa di
seguo qui altri 15 ci purifichiamo
quindi un sacco di gente qualcuno che
salti bravo temerario io non vado a no
perché lo stato su cui ancora il
disastro come fai
ma va bene veramente un casino io
aspetto sempre ragazzi sta tattica qua
non me l'ha fatta vai vai vai veloce
veloce e quella perfetto
elisa è un casino costa fare che si
muove però quanta gente aqualuce
arrivato sembra hexagon chi non c'è più
quella [ __ ] montagna speriamo questa
no ragazzi è bellissimo è un extra con
tutto schiacciato cos'è ci sono le è un
ha schiacciato
una nuova per il ghiaccio che si rompe
no sto male sto male la gente slitta
pure quindi si slitta anche noi ragazzi
quando si slitta un disastro ma scusami
ma non si romperà neanche sito qui due
volte
quanto ci vuole per rom per ste robe a
ok forse di colpire tre volte non lo so
ragazzi di mister sa un po di tempo
sopra ma io sto fermo su una piattaforma
che succede il nostro fermo perché mica
all'intera provincia non aveva provato
la casa penso di tipo sono tutti
sarebbero fermi e già si muove nessuno
la cosa strana ragazzi che non muore
nessuno come fai a far morire io corro
perché tanto ci mettiamo due ore tanto
anche se corro possa andare sulla prima
piattaforma tanto sono tutte attaccate
che mi frega tanto vale corre
dall'inizio ragazzi che cambia può
tenere banco a raga perché la gente
tutta di là è teoricamente verso il
finale inizia a esserci un disastro
perché la giustizia a cadere e vaff
alfano casini
quindi io me ne rimango nella mia zona
non corre porco demonio verrà vagliata
con i popoli
sembra un gioco bene fatta teoricamente
una volta una teca è rimasto solo lui
può venire qua no togliti io non ci ho
fatto ci credo che culo sono andati via
tutti sono rimasti solo io bellissimo
sto male ho vinto la prima la prima
finale che giochi chinai solita verve
bellissimo un genio genio fenomeno pro
gamer che soddisfazione la gara prima
volta che giocavo st finale vinta vita
bellissimo che comunque e sempre hexagon
sono tutto schiaccia non vedo l'utilità
in realtà perché se ci pensate alla fine
non serve a niente perché all'inizio
tutti possono corredato non cani a 31
larga sosta nomi fottono i pugni
mi ha [ __ ] lo stesso però meno di
prima il debolissimo guarda io ho capito
e funziona ciao lavora la differenza
rispetto a prima
incredibile
matic non guardate i miei devo tentare
lì non c'è una tattica sicuro che non
conosco
forse passare all'atto non so però
questi qua vanno evitati in qualche modo
quello sei dimenticato come si gioca
ecco infatti è svenuto va bene va bene
va bene ero in atto fin qua prima non so
come continuare questo traguardo si
perfetto togliti è arrivato settimo va
bene
rispetto alla prima volta è sicuramente
un miglioramento a nadia geana del chip
ciao cerone wind by dovendo queste sono
anche diversi di posizionamento i cosi
che non so come si chiamino i rulli
ma già prima era un casino che non c'è
neanche la strada come faccio e ragazze
un coso che si muove non vedo la
fattibilità di passare di qua non la
vedo non l'avevo non ora spetta petrolio
come si passa non si può
dopo un po in agevole anche se c'è una
strada lino da puoi prendere eccola
eccola ci vado ma ci credo sarà privo di
sanno ha fatto un disastro
servivo non ci credo sono fatta
non so come ho fatto guarda quanta gente
manca ancora con il rullo non ne non è
fattibile
va bene gran finale baffle mountain in
nevada con quello ghiaccio che fa ancora
più schifo di prima che la odio di nuovo
thin ice ragazzi con meno gente di prima
adesso corro subito per ed è comunque
corre all'inizio ha senso tanto non
succede nulla attenzione solaro scivolo
ai ragazzi che trovate qui
a vedersi sembra farsi alla successiva
veramente un disastro
togliti dalle ma cosa fai qui vado è
accaduto chi sta solo bene guarda il
parma sarà il carmelo tali siamo
spostati a vicenda viene proprio carmela
va bene inizia a saltellare laga perché
qua iniziano a esserci poche piattaforme
mica go nelle mutande ok un è morto
mancano tre persone eccole
un altro è morto ne mancano due oltre me
un altro attenzione solo quello ecco ho
visto due volte è caduto secondo le
vinceva lui perché aveva molta più
strada di me cabrio
meno male o ragazzi perbene sono
contentissimo di averli giocato a
folgaria lo portavo due almeno due mesi
secondo momento e 22 mesi due vittorie
di fila bellissimo sfere ragazzi che
video vi sia piaciuta e che le mappe
dove siano stati di vostro gradimento
fatemi sapere se volete altre vite di
foglietti perché non lo stop riportando
perché la un po ripetitivo però queste
mappe nuove sono abbastanza nuove
vigneti iscritti al canale lasciato un
bel mi piace eroico e sempre ci vediamo
da ragazzi
[Musica]